quelqu'un est maintenant Stéphane
Guillon
toujours avec nous en saison 2 voici
Stéphane Guillon la semaine de saison
[Musique]
et voilà et voilà
les vacances c'est fini en été meurtrier
29 polonais tués dans un accident
d'autocar 26 en juillet 3 en août c'est
moins bien une slovène écrasée dans les
Pyrénées l'ours France car après
cannelle exécuté en 2004 et Laurence
Boccolini a battu par TF1
tant couvert pour les plantes tigrades
si dans de manège de canyoning et de
contrôle d'identité pour échapper à la
police
Ivan 12 ans rate un saut de l'ange du 4e
étage être français ça se mérite
n'est-ce pas Jean-François sur ce cliché
notre ministre de l'Immigration et
Jean-Marie Bigard toute l'élégance du
bermuda
en revanche pas d'accident de barque
Sarkozy ne risque rien avec tous les
bourrelets qu'il a se gommer par Paris
Match il flotte
toujours
Saint-Tropez Daddy inaugure la douche au
don Pérignon 150000 € le
rafraîchissement
les enfants du Darfour apprécieront
Paul-Loup Sulitzer a enfin trouvé une
femme qui l'aime pour son physique
Chirac en vacances se distrait avec deux
jeunettes encore une ordonnance de
viagra mal à propos
ils sont préférés la plage
non j'ai dit l'air d'ici là envoyez-moi
les bonnes photos c'est la rentrée quand
même merde
[Rires]
c'est pourri
était pourri pas de canicule cette année
mais rassurez-vous nos vieux sont partis
quand même
merci à eux la chaleur s'était en Grèce
avec un an d'avance la flamme olympique
cabriait partout 50 personnes
carbonisées malheureusement ces deux
vacanciers s'en sortent
François hotland change de copine à quoi
bon me direz-vous c'est toujours lui qui
fait les courses
pour oublier Shazam pratique la boxe
thaï c'est Go il l'aurait bien attrapé
mes poussées un caddie tout seul c'est
pas son truc un été au Pascal Sevran fut
malade aujourd'hui ça va mieux il
reprend ses activités s'il pouvait
tomber malade quand on est rentré ce
serait mieux
[Rires]
citoyen
pour faux championnats du monde
d'athlétisme rappelons tout de même
qu'en juillet c'est un Français qui
réussit à stopper un job en plein vol
[Musique]
gardons champion du monde de rugby
à l'entraînement et là attention ouh là
là un français
arrêtez un peu fou même bouche a perdu
son cerveau ah bon il en avait un
était plus vieux mouvementé mais qui se
termine bien malgré une chute de jet ski
Vincent Lagaf' et toujours vivant ça ça
console de tout
d'autres n'ont pas eu cette chance
rappelons qu'il y a 10 ans tout juste
une Fiat Uno blanche disparaissait sous
le probablement
intitulé la Fiat Uno et moi avec à la
clé un bouquin en ces temps difficiles
pour faire de la thune n'ayons aucune
pudeur à la semaine prochaine merci on
t'écoute fils bien père
alors hier Thierry c'était la journée
mondiale contre la maladie d'Alzheimer
oui c'est ça c'était c'était hier
une maladie grave une seule tentative de
vaccin qui s'est soldée par 18 cas dans
ses falites heureusement les malades ne
portent pas plainte ils se souviennent
pas qu'on les axés
[Applaudissements]
un mâle sournois qui peut frapper la
France entière exemple Jacques Martin
tout le monde l'avait oublié et puis
cette semaine patatras tout le monde
s'en souvient sous vos applaudissements
mesdames et messieurs merci
notamment France 2 qui après avoir viré
l'animateur en 98 la reprogrammée
dimanche dernier comme à la grande
époque un espoir pour tous les
animateurs une fois mort on peut
retrouver sa case
[Applaudissements]
mémoire toujours dimanche c'était la
journée du patrimoine la veille c'était
la journée contre le cancer de la
prostate à cette occasion notre document
de la semaine un monument qui a perdu sa
prostate
j'aime beaucoup ouais je sais c'est j'ai
vu que tu j'aime bien son renard mort
sur la tête on te touche rarement là
vraiment
ah bon
quelle [__] la vie
il fallait y penser c'était le troisième
tiers provisionnel pour les 860 000
malades d'Alzheimer qui ont oublié ses
10% en plus
[Applaudissements]
alzheimer une maladie terrible à 47 ans
50% des cerveaux présenteraient des
lésions voici un grand malade
le 17 mars il déclare la solution c'est
le vote Ségolène Royal six mois après
Ségolène n'est pas taillée pour le rôle
un centre Alzheimer doit accueillir les
vieux socialistes entre ceux qui
trahissent et ceux qui crachent dans la
soupe l'unité devrait fonctionner à bloc
il s'en fout les pas socialistes alors
il est quoi je sais pas
ailleurs dans les étoiles
des malades recensés dans le showbiz
Marc-Olivier Fogiel serait touché sinon
pourquoi VSD publie cette semaine son
emploi du temps
à part lui tout le monde s'en branle
mémoire toujours
souvenons-nous que cette semaine
l'Assemblée a voté le recours au test
ADN c'est vrai évitons le bordel après
on a un président français d'origine
hongroise qui se balade avec les filles
de Jacques Martin comme si c'était les
siennes
avertissement aux enfants de
sans-papiers ne confondez pas Brice de
Nice avec Brice ortefeu
la casse pour faire rire l'autre brise
définitivement
[Applaudissements]
bon conclusion
en conclusion Thierry Alzheimer est une
maladie très grave il y a des cas
tragiques comme celui-ci Bernard
ancien pacifiste et militant socialiste
il bosse aujourd'hui avec la droite et
veut casser la gueule à tout le monde la
dernière chose bien qui lui reste c'est
Christine Ockrent pourvu pourvu qu'il ne
la quitte pas pour Evelyne Thomas à la
semaine prochaine merci
avant de commencer j'aimerais lire un
communiqué à l'antenne ça t'ennuie pas
du tout
suite à l'étranglement d'un chroniqueur
de Télématin par William Leymergie
j'appelle tous les chroniqueurs du PAF à
manifester dimanche à la Bastille stop
au cou au baffe aux injures
même quand nos papiers sont à chier
alors une semaine très positive que de
bonnes idées et on commence avec Marcel
Marceau star mondiale Marcel Marsault
avait appris à Michael Jackson a bougé
son corps très doué Bambi mi met le nez
de Pinocchio avec son sexe
ce qui amusé les enfants
une idée précoce toujours pressée
Sarkozy a rendu hommage au mime Marceau
avec 10 jours d'avance en ne disant rien
pour la mort de Jacques Martin
la dernière idée d'Afflelou pour un
enterrement
la deuxième paire est gratuite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une belle idée maintenant le Mondial gay
de foot a démarré en Argentine sur cette
photo Thierry Henry lors de sa sélection
une idée de fayot mardi France 2
présenter une thématique Nicolas Sarkozy
20h le journal une demi-heure de Sarkozy
20h50 human bombe deux heures de Sarkozy
22h35 Faites entrer l'accusé et là
c'était le fils de Sarkozy
[Applaudissements]
une idée caritative Nikos Aliagas a
chanté à l'Olympia pour la lutte contre
le cancer faut vraiment soigner cette
maladie
[Rires]
après une idée étonnante grâce à l'aide
de Sosie VSD nous dévoile l'intimité des
stars David Beckham au cabinet Mick
Jagger faisant sa lessive plus étonnant
Thierry Ardisson et Marc-Olivier Fogiel
sur le même cliché alors
sosies non mais on s'est mis le plus
loin possible oui c'est vrai mais vous
êtes pareil
pas vraiment ça fait partie de votre
légende vous le savez d'accord
une idée à creuser pour Brice Hortefeu
puisque les sans-papiers se défenessent
lors des contrôles de police le jour les
systématiquement au dernier étage
ça pourrait s'appeler le décret Mike
Brant
[Applaudissements]
une idée risquée liberté pour un
pédophile dangereux grâce au bracelet
électronique donc si ça bip dans une
maternelle c'est ou un portable ou un
pédophile pour réagir très vite
ce genre de plaisanterie chez William
Leymergie c'est une baffe dans la gueule
et on termine avec un grand bravo à
Laure Manaudou on pensait que pour elle
les victoires c'était du passé et bien
cette semaine elle décroche son permis
de conduire merci
pour avoir
[Applaudissements]
ça a permis de conduire
enfin une image d'amour dans un monde de
brut deux éléphants du PS au temps du
bonheur
Ségolène couché sur le flanc attend
l'arrivée de François à la semaine
prochaine
quoi de neuf alors une toute petite
revue de presse aujourd'hui Thierry
service minimum je rappelle que depuis
l'affaire l'énergie les chroniqueurs
sont en grève
notre principal revendications faire
notre chronique équipée d'un collier mou
pour parer à tout risque de
strangulation s'il te plaît merci
beaucoup
c'est un entier en entier trembleur oui
alors c'est très moche
on a l'air d'un con mais c'est la survie
d'une profession qui est en jeu
salut on repassage le très beau geste de
Thierry Ardisson qui remplace Louise
Bourgoin chez Michel Denisot c'est la
première fois qu'un animateur accepte un
boulot de chroniqueurs afin d'en évaluer
les risques au nom de tous mes collègues
Thierry merci
[Applaudissements]
les chroniqueurs subissent des bizutages
insensés pour travailler dans une
émission de Stéphane Bern Jean-Pierre
Mocky a dû déclarer Berne un physique de
cinéma
heureusement il y a aussi
posès cette semaine Thierry Beccaro
reconnaît qu'il doit beaucoup à William
Leymergie
enfin il va se faire étrangler
heureusement il y a aussi de beaux
gestes cette semaine Thierry Beccaro
reconnaît qu'il doit beaucoup à William
Leymergie c'est vrai si l'énergie
n'étrangle pas Jean-Philippe Viaud
Beccaro ne décroche pas qu'un jour de
boulot à France 2
autre mise à pied cette semaine Olivier
Minne son émission s'arrête alors qu'il
n'a buté personne nouvelle politique
France 2
Pascal Bataille convoqué au tribunal de
Bordeaux pour excès de vitesse
pourraient en cas de condamnation
rejoindre très vite la chaîne maintenant
c'est casier judiciaire obligatoire
[Applaudissements]
ça te fait plaisir
allô de consolation toutefois pour
Olivier Minne il produira trois comptes
de 26 minutes jouées par des animateurs
de France Télévisions alors quelques
idées à lui soumettre strangulation
blues avec William Leymergie y a-t-il un
pilote dans l'avion avec Jean-Luc
Delarue et il castrato ou chasseur de
noir avec Pascal Sevran
[Applaudissements]
je vais l'enlever ça m'empêche de
ce qui a vécu Christopher
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors j'ai quand même fait tirer
une revue de presse mais très courte un
service minimum une info du journal auto
plus Nicolas Sarkozy a grillé 8 feu
rouge pris deux contre sens et franchi
une ligne blanche bon on est tous un
petit peu comme ça quand on reçoit une
lettre qui nous dit tu me manques j'ai
envie de toi viens vite
on fonce
Sarkozy toujours le Président remercie
son couturier en revanche pas un mot
pour son chauffeur qui pourtant réalise
des prouesses
à Toulouse vente record pour des pièces
détachées du Concorde c'est fou ce que
ça a pris comme valeur il y a 7 ans à
Gonesse une pièce de concorde c'est
gratos
n'avez qu'à se baisser
l'élève dépasse son maître chroniqueur
en Saône-et-Loire deux enfants de
sans-papiers interdits de cantine par un
maire UMP c'est normal pas de bras pas
de chocolat pas de papier pas de purée
et à ce propos le Front National est au
bord de la faillite bah oui mais bon
Jean-Marie Le Pen aujourd'hui que Brice
sorte de feu lui a piqué son boulot que
voulez-vous qu'il fasse
[Applaudissements]
nouvelle accident mortel avec un chien
il s'agit d'un bébé chihuahua laissé
sans surveillance il leur a fallu
quelques secondes à peine à Magloire
pour le développement
voilà
c'est fini désolé c'est court à la
semaine prochaine merci beaucoup
une revue de presse particulière Thierry
leur n'est plus à la rigolade où est
passé Cécilia s'inquiète la presse
Cécilia première dame de France à temps
partiel
dernier apparition publique enterrement
de Jacques Martin
manifestation sponsorisée par Alain
Afflelou
Cécilia est-elle vraiment partie si l'on
en croit cette info de la page santé de
match l'orgasme est bon pour la migraine
oui oui
pourquoi tout quitter première dame de
France un métier super Bernadette s'est
éclaté comme ce jour où elle a pu
embrasser Rostropovitch mort
un métier
un métier sans SAS mercredi par exemple
tu pouvais faire un tour de 4x4 de nuit
avec Poutine
l'inventeur des cocktails au Pologne
[Applaudissements]
et quand même plus rigolo que de chanter
la pêche aux moules avec un animateur
télé
le week-end dernier Cécilia vous avez
loupé un moment magique les vestiaires
de Cardiff votre mari en costume cravate
entouré de rugbyman en slip
en slip à côté du président ça et la
lettre de Guy Moquet
la Coupe du monde ils vont s'en souvenir
vous auriez pu voir Chabal en vrai
Cécilia Chabal l'innocence brute qui
cette semaine encore demandé à ses
camarades pourquoi lui quand il se
caresse la [__] avec un ballon ça lui
fait rien
après vous avez loupé le resto avec
Macias et sa nouvelle chanson ah
qu'elles sont jolies les filles de mon
pays mais maintenant quand elles
viennent ici il faut qu'elle fasse un
test ADN
au dessert Hortefeu est arrivé avec une
nouvelle idée pour stopper les
sans-papiers un truc essayant Suisse
cette semaine le Taser tu les
électrocutes Sevran vous voulez leur
couper la [__] une idée chasse l'autre
et puis avant de partir Nicolas a
raconté son histoire préférée celle de
Gilbert Montagné le soir de la victoire
quand il pense soutenir ses collègues
royales
la crise
ne partez pas Cécilia je vous ai trouvé
un coach un faiseur de stars un magicien
Dominique bessenard c'est lui qui
s'occupe de Ségolène bah c'est golem
c'est le métamorphose la chrysalide est
devenue papillon c'est dans sa coiffure
son côté Bécassine la Halle aux
vêtements tout ça c'est du stop quand
elle était députée son sac à main
c'était un attachéquelles
t'imagines SOS médecins à l'Assemblée
nationale
passons aujourd'hui c'est gaufres
qu'elle trouve quelqu'un à Julien dress
c'est pas possible tu quittes pas
culbuto pour aller avec landruche
mon rêve c'est un ticket Ségolène
Toretto mais bon Philippe c'est clair ça
à l'Orient ça pour qu'il ait une action
faut lui dire mesdames et messieurs
bonsoir
Cécilia ma puce et quand tu veux ou tu
veux la porte est ouverte tu m'appelles
aller à la semaine prochaine
bravo Stéphane alors une semaine très
noire Thierry pour le gouvernement
défaites en rugby grève générale et
séparation des Sarkozy coacho Figaro
Magazine qui quelques heures avant
France - Angleterre titre le parcours
sportif du 15 de France dans cette Coupe
du monde n'est pas sans évoquer
l'itinéraire politique de Nicolas
Sarkozy
pour une fois qu'on est d'accord avec le
Figaro
on a perdu cette fois aucune image du
président dans les vestiaires une seule
photo parue où l'on sent déjà que la
défaite ça fait mal au cul
la semaine prochaine la porte devient
secrétaire d'État enfin un métier
d'homme adieu l'état fiole il sera
commandé par un vrai demi d'ouverture
Roselyne Bachelot qui cette semaine lui
a déjà claqué son beignet
on a on a perdu du coup le gouvernement
doute hier François Fillon indiquait le
nouveau chiffre de la croissance
dans VSD breath of the flouter ses
enfants blond et habillé en bon point
Édouard Amaury et Maxent non pas à
redouter de tests ADN
[Applaudissements]
pour finir Michel Drucker nous menace je
ne prendrai jamais ma retraite
et on termine avec le vrai coup dur de
la semaine la séparation des Sarkozy
pour l'occasion Frédéric Mitterrand a
souhaité rendre hommage à ce couple
mythique
bonsoir Après le cocorico est masculin
de notre coq gaulois le chant du signe
du couple Sarkozy s'achève sortie sans
gloire pour ceux qu'on surnommate trop
vite les Kennedy à la française
finir au tribunal de Nanterre moins
glamour me direz-vous que le cuir d'une
Lincoln décapotable à Dallas
Nanterre dernier acte d'un improbable
histoire d'amour des marais il y a 20
ans entre un homme politique les député
electe de Jacques Martin au pourquoi
préféré l'austérité froide d'un
ministère aux soirées entre potes où
l'on chante à la pêche au Moule moules
20 ans d'amour ou Cécilia EDA Nicolas à
franchir tous les obstacles comme Calais
un cube sous ses pieds quand il est
assis
20 ans de passion de disputes et de
rabibocharge sur l'oreiller souvenir de
cette nuit torride ovationnée par le
personnel du Fouquet's pourquoi dès lors
après tant d'épreuve tirer sa révérence
est-ce le fruit d'un caractère
exceptionnel ou la peur toute simple
pour une femme de père moldave et de
mère espagnole de subir un test ADN
goodbye Cécilia dommage vous étiez plus
bandante que Bernadette et surtout bravo
pour le coup de l'angine blanche faire
semblant d'être malade pour ne pas
serrer la main d'un homme qui revendique
la torture en Irak chapeau sans vous
Nicolas n'a plus son cube son équilibre
peut-être le début de la fin qui sait
bonsoir
alors cette semaine Thierry une fois de
plus le divorce des Sarkozy Monopolis
que font-ils comment vont-ils alors
honneur aux présidents d'après Paris
Match il est au plus mal le désarroi
titre le magazine plusieurs photos nous
alertes Nicolas comptant les pavés de
l'Élysée
Nicolas seul sur un bateau
plus grave Nicolas refuse de s'alimenter
si Enrico Macias ne chante pas à table
[Applaudissements]
une déprime qui inquiète Nicolas ne doit
jamais rester seul sur cette photo
quatre personnes l'entourent pour aller
aux toilettes
plus rien ne l'amuse dimanche il aurait
boudé sa distraction préférée jouer au
ping-pong avec Gilbert Montagné
alors son de cloche totalement différent
de la part de Catherine Nay Nicolas pète
le feu nous dit-elle il va se griser en
retrouvant tous ceux que Cécilia a
écarté Bernard Laporte pour les bonnes
blagues Didier Barbelivien pour les
veillées entre potes Michel Drucker pour
les sorties en vélo personnellement je
préfère encore compter les pavés
[Applaudissements]
le président ne pense qu'à s'amuser
mardi soir il a éteint toutes les
lumières de l'Elysée pour un cache-cache
géant
il était question d'un shabbit mais
sans Pascal Sevran c'est moins drôle
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas un seul mot d'Orbe distraire
le président pour cette raison Johnny
renonce à la nationalité belge quand
Johnny dit une connerie en Belgique ça
passe pour une phrase normale c'est du
gâchis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et Cécilia comment va-t-elle bien nous
dit match elle affronte sa nouvelle vie
avec détermination et courage attention
voici des images très dures le courage
Cécilia sort de chez Franck et fils
Ralph Lauren Barbara buis Versace etc 8h
de shopping non-stop dans l'Est
Républicain elle annonçait la couleur on
ne m'empêchera pas de soulager la misère
du monde
[Applaudissements]
pour les fiançailles de sa fille Cécilia
s'est surpassé bien choisi évitez les
fautes de goût tout un art chez une
femme qui a enterré son ex-mari en
Afflelou mais divorcé en Ray-Ban
devenir un citoyen lambda oublié les
dorures élyséennes une lutte quotidienne
désormais nous dit match Cécilia conduit
son hostile mini elle-même cela dit une
hostile mini avec chauffeur
[Applaudissements]
alors une nouvelle vie ce sont aussi des
résolutions Cécilia promet de vivre
discrètement et dans l'ombre parole
tenue sur toutes les couvertures
réalisées cette semaine Cécilia aborde
des couleurs sombres automales
automnales pardon toute la discrétion
d'une femme qui a choisi l'ombre ici
l'ombre
[Applaudissements]
et voici en exclusivité la photo la plus
discrète de Cecilia elle dort dans sa
chambre
Nicolas quant à lui ne se consolera pas
dans une carrière de mannequin fonction
oblige dommage lui seul osé marié la
chemise Lacoste et le bermudas à fleurs
voilà pour toutes infos supplémentaires
concernant Cécilia et Nicolas n'hésitez
pas contactez Isabelle Balkany on a tous
une vieille copine qui ne baisse plus
mais qui sait tout sur tout à la semaine
prochaine merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
gratuitement méchant aujourd'hui Thierry
pour les amateurs d'humour noir la
Toussaint est une fête nationale et j'ai
essayé de faire plaisir
ça gaz fut le tout dernier mot d'un
bistrotier à Bondy
la finale de volley assis s'est tenue en
Bosnie cul-de-jatte et unijambiste se
sont affrontés un sport très populaire
au Rwanda avec 100.000 licenciés en
France ça décolle pas trop trop peu de
mine anti personnel ça prend pas quoi
[Applaudissements]
mercredi c'était Halloween aux
États-Unis une société lance le masque
Michael Jackson
grand retard en France où le masque
Régine n'est toujours pas sorti
politique inquiétude après le départ de
Cécilia Nicolas alterne des phases
d'euphorie totale comme ici au Maroc où
il se déguise en Tom Cruise
avec des phases de déprime profonde deux
jours plus tard sous la pluie il demande
à observer des canards
tout est fait pour lui redonner le moral
augmenter son salaire ou encore faire
des paris à la con rouler une pelle à
Rachida Dati
faire de l'auto tamponneuse en pleine
grève des transports
[Rires]
on continue dans la déprime la nouvelle
vie de Chirac titre Le Parisien pose
bien et balade avec sumo
[Rires]
se promener bourré avec un chien par les
temps qui courent c'est pas idéal pourvu
que chez moi n'aille pas bouffé un
nourrisson pendant que Chirac se tape
une mousse
[Applaudissements]
vie sociale enfin un premier mort en
vélib
tout a été fait pour pas de casque
obligatoire couloir de bus dans tous les
sens de la Noé justement récompensée on
le voit comme il a appris la nouvelle
en Seine-Saint-Denis une balle perdue
traverse une salle de classe une façon
rock n' roll de celebrer Guy Moquet
je viens
danserai tout ça moi sauf que cette
pizza
l'homme de Néandertal avait les cheveux
roux découverte faites grâce au
prélèvement ADN une bonne nouvelle pour
tous les sans-papiers rouquins en cas de
litige dites que vous êtes originaire
des grottes de Lascaux
Adjani présente au meeting touche pas à
mon ADN je pensais que Isabelle
défendait l'association touche pas à mon
collagène
télévision
Gérard Jugnot dans Alibaba très beau
casting un regret quand même pourquoi ne
pas avoir pris les dirigeants de ADS
pour incarner les 40 voleurs
[Applaudissements]
Pascal Sevran pourrait animer une
émission de divertissement sur France 2
Sevran on en a dit beaucoup de mal
c'était pas si con son idée de couper la
[__] des noirs on évitait les tests ADN
sport Guy Forget réélu à la tête de
l'équipe de France dorénavant sur tous
les cours de tennis avant de jouer il
faudra lire la lettre de Guy Forget
et on termine on termine par une
déclaration de Nikos Aliagas dans match
je lave le cerveau des tracas du
quotidien
on préfère les tracas du quotidien la
grève les chiens qui bouffent les bébés
tout sauf Nikos Aliagas
merci et
excellent cimetière à tous
alors avant de démarrer petite mise au
point l'humour noir c'est mon Gagnepain
et donc je demanderai à Nico saliagas
qui l'autre soir a annoncé Grégory
Lemarchal en direct live à la télé de ne
pas me piquer mon boulot voilà moi je
cherche pas à être le plus con du PAF et
à m'habiller comme un cake je respecte
le travail des autres
[Applaudissements]
et on démarre avec du cinéma et la
sortie de Mission Impossible 4
bonjour agence Sarkozy votre mission si
vous l'acceptez sera de délivrer cet
otage au Tchad votre contact
Idriss débite attention il y a un piège
les quatre tests espagnols sont habillés
comme des vendeuses de chez Darty
ramenez les directs en Espagne évitez la
France Brice Hortefeux les attend avec
un test ADN aller-retour dans la journée
vous êtes divorcé nous sommes dimanche
ça vous évitera de vous faire chier good
luck
[Applaudissements]
atteint d'hyperactivité Nicolas Sarkozy
prodige sans arrêt des conseils l'autre
jour chez Mohamed VI il indiquait à la
princesse comment isoler un plafond
jamais en reste
pris comment tenir son épouse avec un
poignard
[Applaudissements]
c'est juste un petit peu en dessous des
vannes sur les Roumains mais il y a pas
de problème allez-y monsieur
trop dilettante l'emploi du temps
présidentiel va s'étoffer voici un
programme type midi salon de
l'agriculture 12h30 l'Alpe d'Huez avec
Michel Drucker 13h discussions avec des
marins bretons viens ici si tu as des
couilles 13h30 fête de la saucisse à
Strasbourg 15h marathon de Paris 15h30
marathon de New York le président reste
en basket c'est jouable
[Applaudissements]
l'hyperactivité une maladie grave ce
week-end le président voulait réparer
lui-même les panneaux solaires de la
station spatiale
[Rires]
Christine Lagarde nous donne un conseil
comme rouler moins cette semaine son
conseil quand il pleut trouver quelqu'un
pour tenir votre parapluie
30 clandestins indiens découvert dans
une camionnette c'est encore un conseil
de Christine pour économiser le
carburant privilégier le covoiturage
merci de tester
Rachida Dati candidate dans le 7e cuir
bottes noires basés
attention Bertrand il va falloir être
viril bagarreur impitoyable
[Applaudissements]
sport JO 2008 attention au Mexique qui
actuellement s'entraîne très dur en
natation synchronisée
je suis prête pour une nouvelle carrière
nous non on est on n'est pas on n'est
pas prêt
[Musique]
à quoi ressemblerait Régine si elle
sortait sans maquillage un début de
réponse le visage de Toutankhamon
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est fini pardon un mycose de
mettre énervé j'ai tellement rêvé cet
été qu'il soit bloqué dans les incendies
en Grèce que j'ai c'est vrai tendance à
le prendre un petit peu en grippe c'est
pas bien à la semaine prochaine
à toi mon petit
vous allez être déçu Thierry
ouais je suis en grève comique est un
métier pénible sans aucun répit quand
vous êtes comique il faut l'être tout le
temps comique en vacances comique à la
plage comico ski grand comique polonais
comique au ski
je suis
en grève c'est ça que
plusieurs fédérations défilent demain
notamment la FRG fédération du rire gras
présidé par Jean-Marie Bigard un slip
kangourou géant flottera en tête de
cortège
des actions très dures Charlotte de
Turckheim à menacé de se défaitestrer et
puis comme tout le monde s'en foutait
elle a renoncé
attention le mouvement pourrait
s'amplifier avec une journée Arthur que
des blagues à deux balles mais
rassurez-vous nous n'en sommes pas là
alors
on démarre service minimum Thierry
politique comment Fillon résiste titre
le JDD très dépressif le Premier
ministre travaille désormais en pyjama
réunion du MoDem quand Bayrou fait un
discours même c'est plus proche
collaborateur sans merde
anniversaire pour le 11 novembre des
lycéens ont lu des lettres de poilus
lettre particulièrement rasante voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment le minimum lettre de
poilus extrait quand j'ai perdu face aux
Anglais j'ai chialé comme une gonzesse
Sébastien Chabal notre plus grand poilu
contemporain
social pendant la grève Robert Hossein
fait des prix pour son spectacle n'ayez
pas peur après 8h d'embouteillage se
faire cire 3 heures sur la vie du pape
n'ayez vraiment pas peur
texte Alain Decaux mise en scène aux
scènes il y a pas eu de canicule l'été
dernier voilà le résultat
mais toujours méchant
[Applaudissements]
d'après une étude de la SPA les chiens
martyrisés morde méfiez-vous dolga
Drucker entre les séances de photos
débiles et l'obligation d'assister à
Vivement Dimanche
ne laissez pas un bébé seul devant le
domicile de Michel
Patrick Bruel présidera à l'élection
Miss France 2008 après une rupture
président concours de Miss le meilleur
moyen pour pécho
le violeur des beaux quartiers frappait
chez Jeanne Moreau comme Aurélie Coluche
commissaire Jeanne Moreau
ce soir Nikos Aliagas star de la chanson
en Grèce alors je rappelle que la Grèce
a été ravagée par des incendies un pays
qui adulte Nikos est en état de choc on
pense très fort à eux
voilà
terminons avec un sourire dans ces
périodes de tension sociale il y a aussi
des gestes de solidarité
mal logé l'Élysée intervient pour que le
fils Tapie garde son appartement
chômage François Pinot trouve un boulot
à Claude Chirac
sacrifice l'épreuve de la rue pour
Valérie Pécresse c'est à pied que la
ministre traverse Versailles pour
acheter ses bananes en revanche Arnaud
Lagardère se sent seul ne laissons
personne au bord de la route soyez
généreux camarades aimez votre président
quoi qu'il fasse regardez cette photo
c'est vrai que ce soldat a souffert mais
il repart avec un souvenir à mettre sur
sa table de nuit bouche comme Sarkozy
récompense le mérite ensemble nous
vaincrons
ces jeunes
[Applaudissements]
toute petite précision Thierry
la grève des comics continue les ventes
de carambar sont maintenues il y a des
blagues à l'intérieur et pour ceux qui
sont réellement en manque Rire et
Chansons diffusent les meilleures
histoires de Guy Montagné oui c'est
vraiment un conflit très très dur tenez
bon à la semaine prochaine ah oui c'est
bon
pour la sortie d'un guide gastronomique
Nicolas s'est fait offrir une veste de
chef soigneusement coupé à sa taille
c'est une première c'est une première
une veste de chef qui tient dans un rond
de serviette
pour l'anniversaire de Jacques Chirac
Bernadette lui offre de nuit à l'hôtel
Meurice
si c'est vraiment pour son anniversaire
elle lui laisse la chambre et elle ne
vient pas
grève à force de passer des journées
entières dans leur voiture certains
Français couche avec
[Applaudissements]
ça vous tente ou pas ce genre de
la vérité j'ai peur de comprendre et là
dans le cul la bouteille ou pas non non
il y a pas de bouteille c'est juste
tu vois des trucs qui sont pas vraiment
dans les images
[Applaudissements]
30 passagers de clandestins découverts
dans une camionnette ils ont suivi le
conseil de Christine Lagarde privilégiez
le covoiturage
[Applaudissements]
en Suède les seins nus ne veulent plus
être interdit de piscine
enfin un combat qui vaut le coup de
descendre dans la rue
faits divers dans les Bouches-du-Rhône
le froid fait 4 morts on vous l'a dit
répéter le soir quand vous rentrez chez
vous mettez le chauffage c'est tout con
[Musique]
dans l'Allier trois ados jugés pour
avoir lancé un bébé faut arrêter avec
les bébés on les congèle on les brûle on
les donne aux chiens il est loin le
temps béni où l'on noyait le petit
Grégory dans la Bologne et basta
c'est fait
[Applaudissements]
international la Grèce accusée de
torturer ces immigrés clandestins ici
c'est un immigré grec qui nous torture
tous les vendredis soirs
[Applaudissements]
c'est chiant c'est chiant pourtant on
fait tout pour le mais bon
le premier salon du divorce s'est tenu
en Autriche de nombreuses propositions
pour oublier l'être cher un aller-retour
au Tchad dans l'après-midi et également
un Paris Washington avec escale bretonne
ou un pêcheur peut vous traiter d'enculé
littérature l'Encyclopédie du mauvais
goût est sorti un grand merci à Régine
qui a posé en couverture
mauvais goût toujours alors que le
pouvoir d'achat des Français s'écroule
gala sort un numéro spécial luxe exemple
Joël Robuchon nous propose sa recette du
chou-fleur au caviar pour tous les
pauvres qui nous écoutent privilégiez le
chou-fleur
il y a la s’inquiète aussi du calvaire
du fils Belmondo qui lors du Koh-Lanta
Italie a perdu 16 kilos et ses brisés la
clavicule il n'y a pas que le Bangladesh
showbize dans le Figaro Magazine une
attaque surprenante d'Étienne Daho
contre Mimi Mathy c'est bien de grandir
Kramer contre Kramer titre Galar à
propos des peines de coeur d'Evelyne
Thomas Évelyne Thomas c'est plutôt cramé
super cramé
et on termine en beauté enfin une jolie
photo d'Emmanuel Béart la comédienne
cache ses lèvres elle s'est photoshopée
elle-même
j'ai essayé de faire un papier autour du
gouvernement histoire de faire plaisir à
comme dirait Bedos qu'elle ne soit pas
venue pour rien Morano elle je sais pas
pourquoi elle m'énerve
suite au drame de Villiers-le-Bel salut
en l'initiative de Courbevoie qui grâce
à des simulations d'accident apprends à
ses élèves à éviter les voitures de
police
contre la violence urbaine les policiers
prennent l'hélico c'est pratique qui et
puis il y a peu de motos volantes qui
viennent te barrer la route
international Chine Nicolas Sarkozy très
discret sur les droits de l'homme 8000
condamnés à mort par an une balle dans
la nuque c'est pour ça il faut faire
très gaffe aux Jeux Olympiques cet été
en tir le chinois va être très fort
je rappelle que les inondés du Mexique
sont d'ores et déjà imbattables en
natation synchronisée
d'après Le Figaro la Chine doit cesser
devant les organes de ces condamné à
mort et surtout les yeux parce qu'une
grève Dieu chinoise ça se voit tout de
suite ça se voit
Rama Yade écartée du voyage présidentiel
waouh c'est pas indispensable une
secrétaire d'État droit de l'homme pour
aller en Chine en revanche si Sarkozy va
en Suède Monaco Luxembourg là ouais
ouais
et enclos cette page politique avec un
cliché extrêmement rare Nicolas Sarkozy
assis sans ses annuaires
vu la semaine qu'on est
vers un camion heurte un train régional
bah oui mais bon des jours de grève on a
plus l'habitude de s'arrêter au passage
à niveau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les voiles sur berges passent à 50 km/h
Lady Di c'était battu toute sa vie pour
une vitesse libre en bord de Seine
Marc Lavoine et Patrick Bruel dans la
alors on sait que Bruel traverse une
période difficile
de la choper Marc Lavoine
les mariplake ont des pulsions en ce
moment deuxième photo
tendresse quand tu nous tiens
Yannick Noah bientôt acteur
Yannick Noah qui devait partir si
Sarkozy était président
[Applaudissements]
pour Noël sortie du film Le Renard et
l'Enfant avec tous ces bébés bouffés par
des chiens je sais pas si c'était le bon
moment
Orlando membre du jury Miss France 2008
excellente idée c'est comme demander à
un végétarien délire la meilleure côte
de bœuf
et on termine avec un sourire gala
cherche une femme pour Nicolas Sarkozy
alors plusieurs propositions bon une
fois de plus Nadine n'a pas été retenu
décidément tant mieux plusieurs
propositions la navigatrice Florence
Arthaud oui si elle emmène Sarkozy
autour du monde
Yasmina Reza non elle est d'origine
hongroise de Hongrois ensemble Hortefeux
va gueuler
Inès de la Fressange trop grande un
mètre 80 trop grande
Sharon Stone ça c'est bien Basic
Instinct on décroise les gens le même
geste avec Bernadette Chirac sortez une
frisée 4 jours du frigo vous verrez
voilà moi Sharon Stone qui sort avec le
petit Bonaparte ça me plaît comme ça si
l'ouvre un coup de pic à glace sur la
tronche terminée voilà c'est fini voilà
Stéphane
mais on commence avec l'enquête de la
semaine qui a volé l'esquimau de Nicolas
Sarkozy
c'était la Saint-Nicolas ah bon c'est
pas tous les jours la Saint-Nicolas
[Applaudissements]
Ségolène Royal sur la scène du Théâtre
du Rond-Point alors c'est un one man
show super drôle il y a de l'émotion une
rupture un coach avec un cheveu sur la
langue qui donne des conseils vas-y
c'est got et divines et il y a une fin à
la con alors que ça marche la salle est
acquise elle propose un rôle un grand
nier qui collectionne les tracteurs
[Applaudissements]
c'est dommage c'est dommage parce que
sinon Thierry ça chauffe formidable il y
a du mouvement du rythme et la fin c'est
un crève-cœur
[Applaudissements]
international pour libérer Ingrid
Bettencourt Sarkozy discute avec les
phares on espère que ça va marcher sinon
Renault va faire un nouvel album
[Musique]
Birmanie les claquettes portées par les
moines sont responsables des massacres
bah oui vous avez déjà essayé de courir
en claquettes
le sort des homosexuels chinois
s'améliorent ils font partie intégrante
de la délégation officielle des JO 2008
[Musique]
le coup de fil de l'Elysée aboutine
déchaîne la polémique
de félicitations là j'ai le texte bravo
pour les 200.000 morts en Tchétchénie et
pour ta recette du cocktail au Pologne
j'espère que tu vas réussir à éliminer
Kasparov bien à toi Nicolas quitten
[Applaudissements]
c'est sympa
deux bergers allemands chargés de la
lutte antidrogue ont été décorés oui il
faut que nos amis chiens comprennent
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor que désormais aux
récompensera le mérite un chien qui
trouve de la drogue ce sera une médaille
en revanche un chien qui bouffe un
nourrisson ce sera le tanaisie
[Applaudissements]
27e balle des débutants toutes les
princesses sont trouvées un partenaire
sauf la grande du milieu qui une fois de
plus est rentrée bredouille
[Applaudissements]
télévision le courage de TF1 alors que
la chaîne passe sous la barre des 30%,
elle engage Lorie comme comédienne c'est
une stratégie toucher le fond pour
pouvoir remonter
[Applaudissements]
et puis la réplique cinglante de TF1 au
time qui s'interroge sur la mort de la
culture française Cauet tous les jours à
l'écran des janvier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Geneviève de Fontenay voudrait mourir
sur scène inquiétude c'est la troisième
menace émanant du monde du showbiz je
rappelle les deux premières Dorothée je
suis prête pour une nouvelle carrière
Michel Drucker je ne prendrai jamais ma
retraite
plus d'otages
et on termine avec une étude 96% des
Français jugent la fessée normale pour
les adeptes au ministère de la Justice
Rachida vous accueille derrière le
sourire une poigne de fer écrit match
barrésie et talons aiguille si vous êtes
très très très vilain au ministère de
l'Intérieur si vous êtes gérontophile
MAM c'est son nom de code vous fessera
un gouvernement très hot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà je voulais dire au début de cette
chronique Patrick Poivre d'Arvor
désormais les filles qui travaillent
avec moi récompenseront le mérite à la
semaine prochaine merci
le week-end dernier Disneyland Paris
proposé un nouveau compte de Noël il
était une fois un président fragilisé
par la visite en son palais d'un sale
type très moche pour oublier sa
déconvenue Nicolas pria la princesse
Carla de la compagnie à la parade de
Mickey tour de manège et nuit enflammée
à l'hôtel Bambi suite panpan
le sourire de Carla pourrait effacer la
triste mine de Kadhafi c'est très fort
attention toutefois à la surenchère si
Sarkozy reçoit Ben Laden pour faire
passer la pilule il devra se taper Loana
à l'Aquaboulevard
[Applaudissements]
Nicolas est très fier de sa nouvelle
conquête regardez cette photo après
Vincent Perez Charles Berling mi Jagger
Éric Clapton
qui sait qui a décroché la timbale c'est
bibi
[Applaudissements]
le président ne pense qu'à Carla même
quand il parle politique ces mains le
trahissent on n'a pas couché ensemble le
premier soir on a fait ça le troisième
soir dans une position très classique
celle des missionnaires
[Applaudissements]
car la Bruni une amoureuse effrénée en
2000 elle quitte l'éditeur Jean-Paul
Enthoven pour aller avec son fils
Raphaël Enthoven Jean Sarkozy qui
accompagnait son père dans tous ses
déplacements restera désormais à la
maison
[Applaudissements]
elle connait l'histoire arrière bah oui
elle était là
l'intimité du Président c'est fini les
premières photos de Carla à l'Élysée
circule la chanteuse est assise sur le
pouf préféré de Bernadette Chirac
Bernadette qui a toujours refusé de
poser en nuisette et c'est tant mieux
[Musique]
grand froid je m'adresse au SDF qui ont
installé des tentes en bord de Seine et
qui se sont baignées dimanche Paris
Plage c'est fini il faut attendre out
prochain
[Applaudissements]
et puis fouiller un peu donnez-vous du
mal j'ai avec moi une annonce de
particulier à particulier
alloué boulevard de Port-Royal très bel
appartement 190 mètres carrés vu
Luxembourg 6,30 € le mètre carré c'est
moins cher qu'une tente Décathlon et
vous demandez madame Boutin Christine
[Applaudissements]
Vanessa Paradis reçoit les insignes de
chevaliers des Arts et des Lettres c'est
normal car la Bruni première dame de
France tous les chanteurs s'envoient
seront décorés
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu